une escapade avant que la vie revienne
un peu à la normale
les parents et les enfants anticipe un
retour au travail ou à l'école
mais avec le déconfinement vient un
avertissement dans la région de montréal
on est dans une situation où la marge de
manoeuvre est très mince
la situation au québec demeure
incertaine selon une des projections de
l'institut un déconfinement trop hâtif
pourrait faire augmenter le nombre
d'hospitalisations dans le grand
montréal c'est encore plus fragiles indé
confinement dans deux semaines tel
qu'annoncé pourrait mener à une
augmentation rapide des cas et des décès
je prend la situation très au sérieux
l'infectiologue ne crois pas que la
situation s'améliorera dans deux
semaines et suggère qu'il faut arrêter
de donner de faux espoirs au cours des
prochaines semaines pour faire un effort
supplémentaire pour contrôler davantage
l'épidémie
plutôt que de constamment parler de
déconfinement à montréal je suis
québécois je suis député de montréal je
suis très inquiète pour pour les
citoyens à montréal mais comme chez
inquiet pour les gens à travers le pays
le premier ministre admet du bout des
lèvres éprouvé un malaise envers la
stratégie de déconfinement du
gouvernement le goût je sais que oui il
faut parler de reprendre l'économie de
façon graduelle et progressive mais ça
doit être fait de façon à garder les
gens en sécurité d'abord et avant tout
le député montréalais marc valleur
craint l'effet d'un déconfinement hâtif
sur la population comme sur ses parents
septuagénaires
j'ai par qu'il ya plus de gens qui
meurent premier point g perdre une
deuxième éclosion une plus grande
éclosion la santé publique canadienne
rappelle que le déconfinement doit être
progressif et flexible il faut être très
pourra peut-être ajusté au fur et à
mesure si la situation change
un déconfinement trop hâtif pour
montréal la région la plus durement
touchée au pays et qui est visiblement
le gouvernement fédéral ottawa et québec
ne sont pas complètement sur la même
longueur d'onde mais pour le moment
justin trudeau se contente d'émettre des
réserves sans trop critiquer ici
christian noël radio canada ottawa